it's one of the most unpredictable
general elections in pedus history
18 presidential candidates and pollsters
say
any of the six front runners could reach
the second round
it's an unprecedented scenario fueled by
the pandemic
hours ahead of the vote it was too close
to call
the campaigns have been unusual people
haven't had the chance to meet
candidates there have been hardly any
rallies or town visits
nearly 60 percent of people don't know
the candidates proposals
so they'll be undecided until the last
minute
and this may be why they are undecided
keiko fujimori
running for the third time while under
investigation for corruption
veronica mendoza making a second run
with a progressive left-wing agenda
is ideologically far from the radical
leftist teacher
pedro castillo hernando de soto known
for his controversial theory of beating
poverty
through giving land titles to the poor
has falsely claimed owning
10 doctorates a populist
who says the coronavirus can be cured
with alcohol and salt
and then there is an ultraconservative
rafale lopez who says he practices
self-flagellation when in front of a
pretty woman
but peruvians seem to be more worried
about their health than politics
tens of thousands have died of
coronavirus
cesar gaspar is waiting for news of his
wife in hospital
with all this happening the election
should have been suspended so many
people are dying
and now what a new president what is he
going to do
peru is at the crest of the second wave
of contagion with the brazilian variant
rapidly spreading many are afraid of
catching the coronavirus
posters say they don't know how many
people will not vote
it is a big question for many older
peruvians who are
trying to decide whether to take the
risk of voting and getting
infected at polling stations pollsters
say the candidates on offer are so
unimpressive
voters have been constantly changing
their minds
our findings continue to show that each
week each day
people change their opinion if the
elections were two days or one week
after we would probably see different
results
marita colland waiting for news of her
son ill with covet says
she doesn't know if she will vote they
make so many promises
i hope their hearts are moved and they
take pity on the covert 19 patients
in such a fragmented scenario where not
one candidate holds more than 13 percent
of support in the polls
the only certainty is that there will be
a run of vote in june
[Music]
mariana peru